bei mir schauspielerin und sängerin nena
soukou und musikproduzent george a
wir haben euch gerade schon im video
gesehen vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
für uns die frage an euch beide welchen
satz könnt ihr absolut überhaupt nicht
mehr hören
also ich muss für mich persönlich muss
ich sagen sonst darf ich mal deine
hardware sind den kann und möchte ich
einfach nicht mehr hören denn ich finde
es nicht nur übergriffig jemanden einer
fremden personen in die haare zu fassen
sondern auch ein bisschen eklig wenn ich
mal ehrlich bin denn ich weiß ja nicht
wo die hand von meinem gegenüber schon
war und dann einfach zu sagen darf ich
mal rein und bevor die frage beendet das
hast du schon hand in den haaren es ist
unangenehm und finde ich nicht
angebracht wie oft wurde dir diese frage
schon gestellt also für mich klingt das
jetzt so dass das würde ich niemals tun
also würde ich niemals fragen
das passiert relativ häufig muss ich
ehrlich sagen das ist halt von von von
kleinauf wirst du damit konfrontiert
passiert doch einfach so bisher
irgendwie ein bisschen tanzen und bis
auf toiletten geben er hat auch weil man
hand in den haaren und das ist einfach
ja das ist nicht schön und irgendwie
unangebracht die frage an dich zu
welchen satz kannst du nicht mehr hören
es gibt viele sätze aber um einen
anderen weg vielleicht zu nehmen alle
deutschen sind rassisten den satz kann
ich nicht hören auf grund der
verallgemeinerung weil er natürlich auch
verhindert dass man zueinander findet
wenn man vielleicht vor einer woche sich
zu gemüte führt was hier in deutschland
passiert ist da haben bei diesen
demonstrationen
das war die größte demonstration
außerhalb amerikas hat hier in
deutschland stattgefunden zum tode von
george wright und ich finde das ist
schon ein zeichen was dieses land in die
welt hinaus sendet und auch ein
ausrufezeichen dass man hier gegen
rassismus ist und man muss bei aller
bedauerlich bei allen beteiligten
vorfällen auch immer zeigen was im
umland man hier lebt was ist gerade
angesprochen ist das für euch vielleicht
auch so ein bisschen eine verantwortung
die deutschland hat gerade mit der
geschichte ein größeres zeichen gegen
rassismus zu setzen als jetzt vielleicht
andere länder
also ich denke dass wir in deutschland
weil sie jetzt gerade eben die
geschichtliche erfahrung
auf den tisch gebracht haben ein
werkzeug mit in die hand bekommen haben
das ist teil eins des grundgesetzes die
würde des menschen ist unantastbar
und wenn wir gerade in dieser debatte
den schmerz derer nicht vergessen die
durch rassistische übergriffe leiden
dann sehen wir den menschen aber auch
gleichzeitig müssen wir immer wissen
dass eine generalisierung nicht dazu
führt dass man zueinander findet und der
dialog und das verständnis füreinander
ist extrem wichtig und deswegen ist es
die würde des menschen gilt für beide
seiten
es gibt im moment sehr viele
unsicherheiten wie man das thema black
lifes matter korrekt anspricht das fängt
ja schon oftmals dabei an sagt mainz
afroamerikaner sagt man schwarzer wie
würdest du damit was es so sind so deine
tipps wie geht man damit am besten um
mit dieser debatte jetzt spricht man die
leute richtig an
also ich habe festgestellt dass aktuell
viele meiner freunde auf mich zukommen
und sagen ey ich bin mir unsicher ich
weiß nicht genau wie ich damit umgehen
soll
und das sind immer super schöne
gespräche die wir geführt haben denn am
ende ist eine offene respektvolle
kommunikation und der dialog zwischen
zwei menschen
das was den unterschied macht und wenn
wir empathisch miteinander umgehen wenn
wir uns zuhören wenn wir unser gegenüber
mit respekt behandeln dann glaube ich
dass da das da was ganz tolles
geschaffen wird und dass sich auch
beziehungen auf ganz andere level
erheben können und dass man einfach auf
augenhöhe auf augenhöhe kommunizieren
kann und das glaube ich ist so so der
eine punkt wo ich sage redet miteinander
hört euch zu bewertet euch nicht steckt
euch nicht in schubladen sondern habe
ein offenes ohr und ein offenes herz und
dann wird sich das ändern denn ganz
sicher dass er zwischen freunden bis ein
bisschen einfach aber wenn man sich
jetzt nicht kennt zum beispiel und aber
trotzdem irgendwie interesse für den
menschen hat was glaubt ihr da wie ist
da die beste ansprechverhalten also
grundsätzlich sagt man ja man sollte
immer schwer zu sagen da gibt es das
ponton das ist weiß ja ich denke man
sieht nur mit dem herzen gut es gibt
viele menschen auch draußen auf dem land
dies wirklich gut meint aber die nur mit
am ta-phon und einfach gar keine
begegnungen mit schwarzem oder mit
migranten haben
da kommt es mitunter zu einer gestellten
annäherung aber die absicht ist das was
zählt und man unterscheidet man also ich
für mich kann ich mal sagen ich habe ein
grafisches empfinden dafür mit was für
eine intention jemand auf mich zukommt
und wenn er verbal verrutscht oder
verunglückt dann ist das für mich noch
kein anlass ihn zu bashen sondern dann
nehme ich das erstmal hin und versuchen
eine brücke der kommunikation aufzubauen
und ich glaube das ist das entscheidende
verständnis füreinander
das war die intention wahrnehmen was
will eigentlich der andere denn ich
glaube dass wir in einer zeit nehmen und
wer wir noch die altlasten mit uns
tragen
unser ziel ist es auf jeden fall für die
zukunft eine bessere welt zu kreieren
bei denen dann unsere kinder einfach die
möglichkeit haben unter anderen
voraussetzungen hier in deutschland
anzulegen was glaubt die was muss dafür
passieren
grethen ich glaube wir müssen ganz ganz
viel miteinander sprechen das ist für
mich ist das der der schlüssel gerade
sprechen auch wenn ich auf dem land bin
auch wenn ich die menschen nicht kenne
auch wenn ich das gefühl habe ich werde
gerade bewertet und jemand kommt auf
mich zu und sagt etwas was mich
vielleicht verletzt in dem moment dann
traut kann ich trotzdem mit der person
darüber sprechen und in den dialogen wie
das eben schon angesprochen hat ich
würde noch ergänzend dazu sagen wir
müssen sehr wachsam sein wir haben einen
letzten zeit erlebt dass es hier in
deutschland diesen verunglückten spot
von vw gab ja sicherlich ist das nicht
aus purer absicht geschehen und
inzwischen wissen wir ja dass es
mechanismen waren die dazu geführt haben
dass dieses fauxpas oder dieser
unglückliche spot draußen gelandet ist
er viele menschen verletzt hat aber die
frage ist wie geht ein solcher
weltkonzern mit den verletzungen der um
die darunter zu leiden hatten
das heißt diese wachsamkeit gegenüber
ressentiments und das gilt nicht nur für
schwarze das gilt für viele für frauen
das gilt für lgs das geht für
verschiedene gruppen juden moslems dass
wir einfach achtsamer und sensibler
werden im umgang miteinander und ich
glaube wenn dann der artikel 1 nicht nur
zu besorgen zu besonderen anlässen
zitiert wird oder in besonderen anlässen
zitiert wird sondern auch mal gelebt
wird dann haben wir die chance wirklich
etwas zu verhindern und das wäre auch
wirklich wünschenswert eine
abschließende frage an euch die
demonstrationen die laufen wir auch in
den usa
in den usa hat das so ganz schweren
ausschreitungen geführt was haltet ihr
davon
seid ihr demonstration ja gewalt absolut
nein wie bewertet ihr das was da gerade
auch so ein bisschen passiert also ich
sage demonstration ja demonstrationen
sind wichtig denn es ist wichtig dass
die menschen gehört werden gewalt sage
ich nein denn ich glaube vorher kannst
du nicht mit feuer bekämpfen sondern
halt nur mit wasser also man kann auch
ergänzend dazu sagen wir haben ja dieses
jahr in deutschland ein wunderbares
beispiel liegt im fußball da gab es das
spiel wird wo ich gegen preußen münster
und da wurde ein schwarzer spieler von
würzburg der liebe kwadwo der
rassistisch aus dem fanblock von preußen
münster angegangen und was dann passiert
ist war für mich ein gänsehautmoment
weil die fans von preußen münster
hingegangen sind den pöbler ausfindig
gemacht haben die ordner und die polizei
hinzu gerufen haben und diesen pebler
aus dem stadion raus geschmissen haben
und danach skandierten alle nazis raus
anschließend hat er präsident von
preußen münster noch ein schriftstück
verfasst ein sehr empathisch schreiben
auch in richtung die rückfahrt vom und
ganz klar sich als verein positioniert
und den deutschen fußball auch
gleichzeitig damit positioniert und ich
denke das ist auch eine art haltung zu
zeigen denn nichts ist nichts anderes
ist protest und die begleiterscheinungen
die wir aus amerika gesehen haben
wir sind natürlich sehr bedauerlich aber
es gibt dann anlass dafür und den darf
man jetzt nicht in what about these
manier passieren und man wirklich
wichtiges anliegen hinten anzustellen
vielen vielen dank sozialer und ena
super